in Puerto Rico 44 of the islands 69  hospitals are open and some critically  ill patients need to leave one very  premature baby was put on a plane to  Louisiana yesterday he needs surgery to  connect correct an eye condition that  could cause blindness this little boy  was born weighing just one pound three  ounces he's been on a ventilator since  he was born dr. Jon LaPook  spoke to the doctor who arranged the  evacuation flight we both just watched  the plane take off how do you feel feel  great it was so emotional to see that  plane take off and take that baby the  safe place these babies about to die  was on that plane a little bit of good  news there the baby is expected to spend  months in the hospital